well tony fauci is now a figure of
religious veneration to the kind of
americans who think starbucks makes good
coffee
so it makes sense as a god striding the
earth that tony fauci has his
very own geographic film and he does it
features interviews with boon bono susan
rice bill gates and some of the rest of
the worst people in the world but the
best part of the documentary needless to
say comes from tony fauci himself who is
not surprisingly the world's greatest
fan of tony fauci here for example is
tony fauci explaining why so many
americans don't trust him
i mean i'm the bad guy to an entire
subset of people because i represent
something that is uncomfortable for them
it's called the truth
[Music]
they can't handle the truth those
americans
keep in mind some people may distrust
tony fauci for other reasons like he's a
liar and he's admitted it he lied about
scientific data for example about herd
immunity and he's admitted it
but in the documentary tony fauci's
taken the long view and he's begging
historians to forget all of that
i hope that if historians look back
if they ever would want to look back
at what i've done
in my life
maybe somebody says hey
that guy was pretty good
uh-huh so there's a vaccinated man
wearing a mask alone outside that's
clearly a sign of mental illness
but the film makes it seem like heroism
what do we make of this jesse waters is
the host of waters world and the author
of the fantastic book how i saved the
world which he basically did he joins us
to assess the tony fouchy movie jesse
waters have you seen this
no and i don't plan on it but he really
is the perfect hollywood actress craves
attention loves drama and if you
criticize his performance oh they only
hate me because i'm beautiful
this is the thing
we don't hate the truth we just want
tony to tell it and we we trust the
science we just don't trust that
scientist because tucker this is the
same guy that funded the risky research
in that sloppy lab that sprung this
pandemic and then he
kept us all locked inside to protect us
from a virus that mostly spreads inside
so instead of resigning and doing the
right thing he goes on television and
actually suggests that future historians
document his life and treat him as a
hero now as someone with a healthy ego
tucker even i
blush at something like that but maybe
this is just
satire from disney i mean they do use
susan rice as a character witness for
anthony fauci the benghazi bag lady or
maybe this is just
disney paying fouchy back because disney
shares did go up a hundred percent
during the fouchy lockdowns remember
everybody just sat home and watched
disney plus
and they got all those beijing profits
coming in because tony ran interference
for the lab leak so maybe it's just
payback
but what about the filmmakers i mean if
you're interviewing the guy who helped
create covid19 lied about it got caught
funded these frankenstein experiments
that wrecked the united states wouldn't
you feel obligated to ask him about it
it's too late because now the media has
anointed him remember he's
lord lockdown arch enemy of donald trump
savior of everything scientific and holy
the media were early investors
in the fouchy narrative remember they
rode the fouchy wave from the lockdowns
to the ballots all the way to power in
the white house same with big tech and
big farmer they're in on this too he's
too big to fail
they can't pump and dump and sell them
like they did cuomo they can't burst the
fouchy bubble right there's too much
money locked in the guy's uncancelable
um even though he's about yay big
that is such a sm they can't pump and
dump like they did cuomo i wish i
thought of that man is that perfect
jesse waters thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else